[Música]
[Aplausos]
tive a oportunidade de passar algumas
vezes momentos com vocês estão passando
aí sentados absorvente idéias
há algumas outras oportunidades de curar
eventos como esse como ted x e é uma
honra muito grande poder pisar no palco
de 17 x para falar justamente sobre
aquilo que a gente escutou até agora o
poder que as idéias têm para transformar
o mundo principalmente porque todos nós
que somos que estamos aqui nós somos
inseguros
a gente tem medo a gente tem medo do
novo a gente tem medo do diferente a
gente tem medo daquilo que sai do padrão
que a gente conhece mas ao mesmo tempo a
gente adora tecnologia a gente gosta
muito de tecnologia a gente possa
experimentar coisas novas aplicativos
novos redes sociais novas guerras que a
gente coloca no carro enfim uma
infinidade de coisas são diferentes a
gente adora experimentar mas a gente se
sente confortável a gente só gosta da
inovação quando a gente se sente seguro
com ela quando a gente vê o benefício
que ela tem pra gente que ela traz pra
gente como aquilo facilita a nossa vida
é engraçado porque se a gente tem seguro
e se a gente gosta de tecnologia do novo
é é quase um conflito né
mas é importante lembrar também que o
que é sinônimo de segurança pra mim pode
não ser sinal de segurança pra vocês eu
adoro mergulhar pra mim tá 30 metros de
profundidade no mar é um ambiente seguro
para muitos de vocês deve ser um
ambiente de pânico
pra mim tá certo até hoje deu tudo certo
as idéias é um tem um poder incrível
para impactar e transformar o mundo
transformar aquilo que a gente conhece
para provocar a gente e ao longo dos
anos várias idéias mudaram radicalmente
a forma como a gente se relaciona com o
mundo e eu queria contar
duas delas pra vocês neste momento teve
uma época no começo do século passado
onde um cara resolveu criar uma máquina
que pudesse levar pessoas de um lugar
para o outro
uma coisa que causava medo quando a
gente sente medo nosso corpo muda
quando o nosso corpo muda a gente fica
mais atento a gente fica mais ansioso a
nossa mão começa a transpirar
o coração acelera a gente é adrenalina
começa a correr pelas nossas veias
o medo causa tudo isso a gente um novo
causa isso essa invenção causou isso
mas a gente pensar também que a euforia
causa o mesmo tipo de reação à euforia
ela causa a a agente ficar mais atento
a gente fica mais entusiasmado com o que
está acontecendo e tem o conecta essas
duas coisas o que causa esses dois tipos
de sentimentos agentes são as idéias
então a primeira ideia que eu trouxe pra
vocês
está complicado aqui é invenção 9906
santos dumont colocou essa máquina
provou a essa máquina que transformou
radicalmente a forma como a gente se
relaciona com o mundo
a forma como a gente se relacionar com
pessoas a forma como a gente se
relaciona com culturas com ideias
diferentes
qualquer um de nós aqui consegue sair
agora do ted x volta redonda em 33 horas
está na china do outro lado do planeta
terra ao que era imaginável naquela
época foi considerado louco por isso
trinta anos depois teve um outro cara
henry ford que fundou uma empresa com o
seu nome que resolveu massifica a
produção de carros
o idec já havia já existia né a produção
do carro em si e ele resolveu tornar
isso acessível a um número cada vez
maior de pessoas fazer uma produção em
série
o dias em taiwan o carro revolucionar a
nossa forma a forma de se relacionar com
as cidades da nossa integração com as
cidades
a nossa interação entre a gente tem
gente no brasil que considera o carro um
membro da família quase todo domingo dá
banho lustra é uma coisa incrível carro
o mais interessante de idéias é que elas
nunca são um fim em si ela sempre
transformam o trazem coisas novas
as idéias elas são molas propulsoras
para novas idéias
a invenção do carro a produção em série
na verdade do carro na popularização do
carro a trouxe outras inovações
legislações inovações da segurança como
cinto de segurança à luz de alerta e
vários anos depois o air bag
é uma inovação uma ideia que deu origem
a outras ideias foi o carro também que
proporcionou que em 2009 dois caras que
estavam na conferência leweb na frança
saíram tarde desta conferência estava
voltando pro tal eles não conseguiam
mais um carro na rua não conseguir um
táxi é super difícil conseguir um táxi a
fora do centro de paris tarde na noite
ainda mais transporte público já não
estava mais acessível e sequer estavam
caminhando de volta para o hotel
resolveram parar num num café em um
deles ele falou cara já pensou assim que
eu fosse a gente pudesse pegar o celular
do bolso apertar um botão em poucos
minutos um carro na nossa frente para
levar gente para onde a gente quiser e
obter uma realidade em 32 cidades do
brasil 480 no mundo graças à
popularização do carro a invenção da
internet ao smartphone várias idéias que
ao longo dos anos possibilitaram alguém
pensar nisso e todo mundo que tá nessa
sala hoje todo mundo que está aqui com
certeza tem idéia o tempo inteiro
com certeza a gente teve milhares de
idéias ao longo do dia de hoje escutando
tudo que a gente escutou mas o que
diferencia gente um dos outros é
justamente o que a gente faz com essas
idéias como a gente coloca essas idéias
em prática para que elas possam ser
amplificadas impactar o mundo idéia no
papel não vale absolutamente nada
quando a gente coloca uma idéia em
prática assim ela começa a ter valor e
pessoas têm idéias idéias podem
transformar o mundo como a gente viu nos
exemplos até agora e todos nós devemos
ser catalisadores pessoas que entendem
interpretam analisa idéias e contam
idéias para outras pessoas para cada vez
um tá mais gente em prol de uma idéia de
algo que possa ser transformador jogo
que possa ser impactante numa sociedade
todo mundo que tem capacidade pra isso
eu acredito piamente nisso em dar um
impulso para várias idéias boas mas eu
acredito que tem uma área do
conhecimento que consegue fazer isso de
uma maneira ainda mais transformadora
são pessoas que estudam como trazer
gente pra perto de uma idéia de um
propósito trabalham com empresas com
ongs com governos com outras pessoas
para poder lapidar
para poder interpretar suas idéias e
contar a elas um número cada vez maior
de pessoas para que mais gente possa se
conectar com essa ideia possa trazer
conhecimento diverso porque diversidade
é fundamental para a gente colocar
coisas em prática então consiga gerar
impacto no mundo ou relações públicas
desse profissional é a profissão que eu
escolhi
é uma profissão uma área da comunicação
que estuda todas as demais áreas
a gente estuda como usar cada ferramenta
o que a gente tem dentro da comunicação
para tornar mais simples o entendimento
de uma idéia de um propósito e tornando
entendimento mais simples maiores são as
chances de outras pessoas compreender
essa idéia se conectarem com ela e ao se
conectarem com ela somarem a ela e
transformarem as ideia e gerarem mais
impacto no mundo eu acho que o rp um
amplificador de idéias
é por isso que alguns anos atrás eu me
conectei com outras pessoas que pensam
da mesma forma que eu ea gente resolveu
fundar uma escola que trabalha com
educação complementar uma escola que vai
buscar na prática conhecimento para
levar para a teoria espalhar isso o
número maior de pessoas para que mais
pessoas possam se inspirar a aumentar o
seu repertório aumentar o seu
conhecimento e trabalhar para disseminar
cada vez mais idéias para que a gente
possa colocá las em prática uma idéia
super simples que foi criada pela área
de rp o que digo é ter 6 e universo das
relações públicas é é uma idéia do
imortal fãs que foi criada pelo sport
clube recife
eles criaram uma carteirinha que dizia
que aquela pessoa que tinha aquela
caterina era um doador de órgãos
uma idéia super simples numa região onde
as filas para a doação de órgãos são
altíssimas ea mortalidade é muito alto
também
em pouco tempo eles conseguiram juntar
51 mil pessoas que se declararam
doadores de órgãos e isso auxiliar
justamente no momento mais difícil que
era teu sim da família para que aquela
pessoa seja um doador e 51 mil pessoas
significa mais gente do que cabe dentro
do estádio do sport clube recife
mulher simples que impactam na região
conhecimento é a chave para isso quanto
mais a gente conhece mas a gente aprende
maior o nosso repertório maior só a
maior a chance de a gente conseguir
fazer conexões incríveis da gente
e consegui é fazer ligação entre pontos
e da gente aprender coisas diferentes
a gente viu aqui hoje que a realidade de
um é muito diferente da realidade de
outro a gente tem realidades diferentes
aqui dentro desta sala imagine a
diversidade ea pluralidade de diferenças
de idéias que a gente tem ao redor do
mundo todo
o senhor quer nos shoppings o que esse
cara aí ele disse que é papel do
conhecimento levar a gente em direção ao
futuro
ele falou isso numa das primeiras
cidades toques feitas na na história do
ted em 2006 levar gente em direção ao
futuro onde as ideias que a gente tem
hoje vão ser postas em prática onde a
gente vai ter passado pelo processo de
ter receio por essa ideia e depois
assumir e interiorizar essa idéia
com certeza o smartphone causa impacto e
muita gente ouviu nascimento do iphone
por exemplo né
não faz muito tempo e isso impacta a
nossa vida até hoje você tem um
aplicativo para tudo cá dentro do seu
bolso e se é papel do conhecimento levar
a gente para esse futuro quanto mais a
gente conhece mais a gente estuda mas a
gente aprende mais a gente aumenta o
nosso repertório ao longo do tempo
melhores idéias a gente vai ter mais a
gente vai conseguir juntar gente mora
essa capacidade delas gerar um impacto
real no mundo principalmente aquelas que
conectam gente que trabalham a em prol
de transformar o mundo num lugar melhor
eu acredito muito nisso idéias
conhecimento impacto no mundo com esta
ideia que pode impactar o mundo que
aquilo que você tem vontade de contar
para mais gente e que pode gerar real
impacto na vida de mais pessoas
você está preparado com todo o
conhecimento que você precisa para
colocar essa idéia em prática
eu acho que se a gente quer olhar para
as idades além do aço
se a gente olhar o mundo diferente um
mundo de gente possa ser mais humano e
se conectar e a gente possa viver mais
em harmonia com respeito e com
diversidade
a gente precisa pensar um pouco mais
sobre essas três coisinhas
idéias conhecimento e impacto no mundo
obrigado
[Aplausos]